hello there recheck nation I'm Craig
this is Amy our bird who has brought
over these treats that I have wrapped up
and I'm sorry what were you posting that
video I'm posting that video tomorrow of
me making them actually on YouTube on
the YouTube what do you know I didn't
even know that go check out Amy art
burns YouTube channel people it's been
going great last time she was here it
was just an announcement video that was
up and now she has been uploading
consistently and she is killing the game
make sure to go check her out her
channel soon as you can and I also found
out Amy is a huge Star Wars fan and then
to pander she wore this Empire Strikes
Back shirt which I just really want us
turday mind yeah number one for me is
Phantom Menace number two would be
Attack of the Clones
okay number three's the last Jedi okay
number four is Return of the Jedi the
last ones I'm watch this video from Luke
Kurt called Jedi ranks fully explained I
can't fully explain it neither can this
new franchises Star Wars it's all about
the meta chlorine count guys that's what
it's about any chlorine count must be
high you were these uncomfortable
headphones okay really nice you don't
remember that no we didn't do this last
time we were headphones no yeah we did
I'm pretty sure we didn't I'm pretty
sure all right then you know no
headphones I don't mind
no no they look terrible on you everyone
knows what a Jedi is but who's in charge
of the Jedi Order and what happens to
trainees who don't pass their test I
have no idea here are Eve the galaxy's
guardians of justice and peace here's
your guide the lowest ranked in the Jedi
hierarchy are young like younglings
also known as initiates according to the
book jaw versus if the essential guide
to the force younglings are children
sensitive to the force who are gathered
from across
the galaxy is infants to be turning this
future Jedi the Jedi man got an annual
for students of the forest explains that
at one time young adults and adolescents
were recruited as Jedi younglings but
the order found that these older
recruits were already exposed to
negative emotions that could push them
to the dark side as a result the Jedi
began recruiting children who were
younger and more innocent younglings
don't train with mentors that's why they
really were okay plans and train
together within those whenever they're
like they're too old
the emotional trials which have included
such tasks as building a lightsaber
though the initiative changed over time
their ultimate goal is to determine
students knowledge of the Jedi Code and
ability to conquer the dark side unlike
the group training for younglings
Padawans receive one-on-one coaching
emulated mission have caused significant
hurdle for most Padawans to clear trials
to move up in rank these tests include
the trial of CL the trial of courage the
trial of flesh the trial of spirit and
the trial of insight laurels test the
Padawans mental and physical abilities
and determine if they are ready to be
unsuccessful initiatives can still
become members of the Jedi service for
the organization is separated into four
arms agricultural medical educational
and explore a brand new formation Alcor
uses the force to help ensure that the
Republic has enough food to go around
the Medical Corps is considered one of
the most advanced medical organizations
in the Republic with its members
performing specialized procedures and
triage work on battlefields across the
galaxy as you guys are done the movies
are - translating and obtaining records
the most exciting branch is arguably the
exploration Corps whose members are sent
to the park long corners of space to
make new discoveries Jedi Knights are
full-fledged members of the Orphic
aspect is a whole piece of morals of the
Jedi the most common way to become a
Jedi Knight is by passing trials as a
Padawan but an individual can also be
granted the title by performing a heroic
deed like obi-wan Kenobi assuming the
rank after defeating Darth Maul at this
point in the hierarchy Jedi Knights
still have much to learn about the force
but they no longer carry out their
duties under the direct supervision of a
Jedi Master
most Jedi Knights carry out their
missions alone testing their
self-discipline and upholding the
principles of the Jedi Code when people
think of the Jedi two things usually
comes to mind the force and lightsabers
who are the Jedi in many cases those who
specialized in the manipulation of the
forest pursue the title of Jedi Council
are most of these Jedi are focused on
using their connection to the forest to
resolve conflicts in a peaceful way the
most esteemed Jedi consular masters
serve on the reconciliation council a
select group of Jedi who work directly I
worked out really well for meditation to
connect to the forest and receive
visions of the past present and future
for instance the process called the one
who will bring balance to the forest was
the product additions received by Jedi
Cedars yeah or did their findings in the
Jedi archives other counselors become
Jedi healers we use their connection to
the
or estimate broken bodies other's work
as Jedi ambassadors and Jedi diplomat
serving as representatives and various
government bodies and activist movements
respectively
other councillors might become Jedi lore
keepers dedicated to maintain original
parasites in the years leading up to the
Clone Wars the Republican Party and
there's layers three main subclasses
peacekeepers simple security and
starfighters peacekeepers act as the
lactic police strain and crowd control
and de-escalation of threats all right
keep it moving nelly additi gifted Jedi
guardians may be known as battle masters
tasked with teaching lightsaber form and
technique or Cadence's to Jedi in train
cool some guardians come to specialize
in fighting with weapons other than a
lightsaber
these weapons include whips wails
blasters and even double bladed
lightsaber the orders wild cards
sentinels pursue training and
disciplines that are also available to
non-for since they love this to the JI
orders ancient teachings and pursue
certain tools include specializing in
computer systems manipulation of
technology and hacking into and
disabling security mechanisms other
sentinels do exceedingly well on
missions that require stealth and
infiltration one particular group of
sentinels known as the Jedi shadows
service he orders assassins in excel at
sneaky less combat oriented tasks Jenai
sentinels have also distinguished by
often remaining in one area for much
longer than other Jedi acting as
watchman for particular regions of the
galaxy just be a Jedi shadow an
exemplary skill deep knowledge of the
force and successfully trained in a
princess to become a Jedi Knight they
may be great
[Music]
are known as the counselor to get on the
order was a lifetime appointee Mace
Windu's began after Windu decided to
take a more active role in commanding
troops on the battlefield and insisted
that the title be passed to Master Yoda
the order is a prestigious position they
are still outrank by one final position
in conjunction with the master of the
title Grand Master during the Clone Wars
Master Yoda was recognized as the Grand
Master of the Jedi Order afterward at
least until the universe looks Skywalker
in both the title of Grand Master is he
rebuilt the gym on the right looks like
Marlon Brando Empire Luke Skywalker
became an Iran there are no no II left
there's so much more it's weird because
I started a few weeks ago that I was
like I'm leading up to rise of Skywalker
I'm going to watch the Star Wars movies
just the Skywalker saga in timeline
order as of filming this yesterday I
finished Empire Strikes Back and you
know of course been watching the
Mandalorian and I've been watching like
all these things just to get more of the
Lord I've always been into the movies
for some reason lately I feel like I've
truly been getting it like with the
force on this one
I've always just watched the movies and
I really like the movies and I guess
that's the different paths that I've
been going down I've been obsessed with
wanting to know more about the lore so
I've started the Clone Wars and
everything I want I just want to get it
all down so like watching videos like
this have been a big reward for me
lately it's helping me grasp it more can
you believe George Lucas came up with
all this on his own an army the Jedi
they have all the divisions yeah this
whole division they have their diplomats
they have their like it's crazy and Rey
skipped all of this that happens when an
entire order is rages gets to do
anything she wants not the standard
track no training required or anything
like yeah like I just assumed if you
were a Jedi you were a Jedi Knight like
those things were synonymous to be fair
the movies don't make it clear not at
all like I've made it from episode one
Episode five and that portion they would
probably have made it pretty clear
yeah that's why learning upon this
expanded lore has been really
fascinating to me because it makes me
want to see kind of what they've been
doing with the Mandalorian it'd be cool
to see some type of Jedi show that
really helps yeah we're in the skywalker
timeline that would it be way before way
after all this would have to be within
the prequel timeline because order 66 oh
my god I even remembered order 66 66
have like that all the Jedi say I mean
it would have to be somewhere around
there but either way it's it's so crazy
to me that George Lucas came up with one
movie handed off like Empire Strikes
Back you didn't even write that or
direct it it's just the stories by him
like he's very involved as a producer
coming up with the story for it actually
it's easy for people to forget who even
directed that movie yeah and then to see
how much the lore has just outlived like
out expanded past and where sometimes
you don't even associate it with George
Lucas I know that's crazy and I imagine
there's some of this stuff that you
cause like you're referencing the books
the comics the animated TV shows all
these things I'm sure there are
arguments out there
about like what's Canon the real thing
and like which of those the books or the
Clone Wars what is considered official
versus fans know there's a whole
Mandalorian I guess Mandalorian
documentary that explained the entire
like for twenty thousand years or
something like that
crazy lore behind them and then all
these different rings so the Jedi would
make sense
they're talking about like the stealth
Jedi's I don't like I want to see that
no I don't want to see that care I'm
sure there's some some of these that
must be present in the shows and I'm not
yet up-to-date with as I was watching
this my whole experience with binging
the movies a big part that I'm looking
out for with myself was as I'm someone
who actually loved the last Jedi as
divisive as it was for everyone I loved
it as a film and what everyone has been
telling me it's a really good Rian
Johnson movie it's not a good Star Wars
movie one of my goals were with doing
this is by the time I get to last Jedi I
want to be able to see what people mean
by that yeah and if I agree with it and
then watching this video
oh damn Nate's our Luke into that guy
watching these movies is making well
Luke has always been tempted by the dark
side Yoda is even like he's too old he's
got a lot of anger in him like his
father like they drop all these things
so he can make sense but Luke was but
when Luke goes a little dark and kind of
in like a cynical and resentful of the
Jedi but he's like Grand Master right
according to this lore and who decided
ya know I'd be curious to know do you
just go into the field that you are best
suited for or do you get to choose like
if I want to be a doctor Jedi or a
medical Jedi or whatever that category
was based off the way the movies have
portrayed the Jedi Council makes it seem
like they're kind of always choosing for
you where you go now
yeah and that makes sense because Jedi
are supposed to be like completely
selfish beings like I will go where I'm
best suited I will want to stay a
youngling the whole time and then I
would no no would never go to Padawan I
never get to build your own lightsaber I
would just go to a different galaxy
called galaxy's edge to it and just
travel the earth I want my my my
lightsaber and then go back home we're
going next week my girlfriend I haven't
been in Disneyland in about a week like
four years like four years created by a
person who definitely wasn't sexist or
racist or anti-semitic guys subscribe to
looper subscribe to the rejects
check out Amy our Burns YouTube channel
as soon as you can or else she won't
return she doesn't believe in
friendships only networking take it from
me I like to end this with a page of the
day shout out to a man named Chris wham
off does an eccentric weymouth anyway
Chris is one of those guys who helps out
a lot with his community like really
gets involved with helping out people
who are more unfortunate than himself us
being one of them and he's just such a
great kind-hearted guy that i think
chris if you were to become a Jedi or at
least pursue that path I don't think
they would deny you and say you're too
old they would be like you're medic
Lorien count is high and you aren't full
of nothing but light so you're gonna go
straight to the Jedi Council that's how
good you are I know right that's like a
little jealous actually use that as your
future pick up line every girl at a bar
will totally get your medical area
[Laughter]
there you go straight to the Jedi
Council you know I'm saying what the
hell are you talking like with me I got
a meme usually use that line when you
meet a meme
during the Han Solo point thank you
Chris